howdy he'll reject nation I'm Greg Alba
here John Humphrey is me we are going to
watch today a short film called what's
next I'll tell you what's next a
reaction didn't review to your short
film is what's next Jean get her cheddar
Gigi Jeter Derek Jeter we are doing this
because one of our reward tiers on
patreon because yes we do TV show
reactions and weekly Q&A is over there
but one of our top reward tiers is
whatever video your request we must
definitely cover and put up on the
youtubes which occasionally lends itself
to us covering aspiring filmmakers short
films and today's is jean getter Gigi
look before you get proper shout out
let's watch this and criticize the hell
out of your work yeah guards pail
dumpster situation going on outside
right now sorry about that
professional strip
she's cute folks like this already
[Music]
[Music]
if this is the whole short film I'd be
okay
[Music]
Stephen Ramirez is next then Lauren E
Butler is next next assuming she's
Lauren
wow what a name that is
[Music]
gaijin is your short film money saving I
I started dating a few months ago
everything was going well until she was
convinced that he cheated after getting
caught in a brief rain shower steal read
her palm to explain I had just arrived
me here get him talk there's nothing to
talk about
there's a lot to talk about maybe to you
please at least hear me out
you could have already started I know
hurry sit down are you crazy or
something you know I'm not what I don't
know what are you doing here can we talk
we have nothing to talk about there is a
lot to talk about please at least hear
me out okay fine can we sit down what
the hell only has it been today makes
two hundred and fifty one days two
hundred and this can't be happening I
know I need more me too this can't be
the end
it's not there's more to come I can feel
it
she's working on everything else except
for us she does have the confidence
anymore the way we met that was
beautiful I know and it felt like
yesterday the wining the party the song
don't remember the wine
something I've noticed every box oh [ __ ]
I remember the party but I don't know
where it was can I have a makeup sexy I
thought we had beer I hate beer uh what
are you doing you can't get out I know
me too
she leave us here with nothing to do on
you really give us something to do
it's like book characters she doesn't
care about there's nothing she does
she's to use her time but she still
cares and one old Iraqi we hear all
those voices we hear around us and
outside in other rooms whose voices or
characters and other stories Hey
looking up with something to fix things
I think today she is going to write more
yes she sat back at the computer yeah I
think she's thinking stop thinking start
typing yeah come on come on yes she's
typing wait what she didn't type
anything new she changed my name
I'm Stephanie you're not Stephanie
that's okay what's in a name well she
didn't change your knee she's a smart
woman ha ha whoa whoa what was that she
deleted something he's not right whoa I
can't see her neither
she got really you know what's happening
right deleted tell me like I told you
before she doesn't care about us
just tell me she throws in the trash for
nothing she's just gonna find the right
words you didn't even get to find out
what genre words characters aren't
coming back no murderer
[Music]
I want to do what I see interesting
that's quite interesting I wonder how
much of this is inspired by jeans real
life in some capacity because he did
mention he was an author to me what's
your action sci-fi supernatural drama
that's right all those genres all facts
which are all present right here no I
mean I noticed one or jeans not a woman
so that can't be him there maybe it's
just a side of jeans personality I mean
it's a cool concept I really I really
appreciate the concept of you know
you're writing in the characters you
bring them to life you know and a lot of
times whenever I hear writers
screenwriters or directors talk about
screenplays it's like you got to treat
these characters as if they're real
people so taking the approach of writing
something it's it's kind of like the
movie stranger than fiction but not
exactly because Will Ferrell's character
is a real person and she just happens to
be controlling his life where this is
like she created these characters and
now these characters are brought to life
yeah it's like imagining the world of a
book as being its own place where
characters reside and can kind of sense
the world around them and I appreciate
that like that was something I kind of
had to piece together over time I
honestly I don't think you need to hit
it on the nose as hard towards the end
when they're like we're in a book we're
waiting for her to write about us you
know certain things like that I might
have refined it depends because there
were times where I was a little bit
confused as to is this supposed to be
comedic or is this supposed to be like
deep and dramatic because they're sort
of like inserts and then like the way
they reacted things that play like a
comedy to me which I enjoyed and then
things like that that are on the nose
very expositional like those could have
worked better if the tone of whether or
not to comedy or not yeah it would have
hit the other like the concept itself is
great and the actors yeah yeah I feel
like going forward you would probably
want maybe some more seasoned actors at
least you know you guys you got here or
pretty green because yeah I mean we've
seen your Instagram page before you're a
photographer so you know how to shoot do
you know how do you know
frame and stuff yeah exactly and I like
the idea of primarily keeping this with
a couple of a two-shot so you're just
observing them and watching them and
they even like the opening shot of
you're just looking at the author issues
just brainstorming as you keep shooting
you probably just keep fine-tuning your
skills and what you're doing here yeah I
mean III get this sense that you are
very much writer and very much an
intellect so I guess going into your
next piece your next project I would
just maybe put a little more into adding
more flavor to the angles and stuff like
that I mean this I got the sense was
very simple and I wonder how long you
made this into cuz you know there's a
lot of straight on shots I mean I like
some the ideas you had like with these
silhouetted profiles that are kind of
reversing back and forth and then we
switch over to them in the piano I feel
like those are probably conscious
choices you made so in you know moving
forward how does maybe make those visual
cues a bit more distinct and it's just a
smooth out some of those jump cuts yes
man some of the jump cuts maybe get some
type of you know we're not one to talk
about sound too much but when we do our
short films we care about sound a lot
oh yeah the more you can help your sound
the more smooth everything will go
there's something weird about short
films and indie films that the most
distracting element can be sound that is
not quite there that's when it can pull
you out the most and literally if you
were just to get like a mic or something
like that or have someone do a boom for
you that would drastically improve
everything like you in a matter of fact
you could have that shot the exact same
way no but the sound was there what it
made like this huge world of difference
yeah weird how that goes and that's just
you know the growing pains you figure
out when you're making stuff at all you
know cuz sound is so easy not to factor
in as heavily as you might factor in the
script or the visuals or whatever yeah
and with some of these like I like these
little superimpositions you have that
signal that she's at the computer doing
something to their world maybe in future
you might want to try and capture some
of those in camera maybe just to make
them feel a bit more tangible but I like
the concept especially is it unfolded I
appreciate it having the idea of okay
this isn't just a couple spat this is
two characters kind of trying to figure
out what they're doing inside of their
own story like it's meta in that way and
I like where you're headed with that
yeah yeah totally I mean I think the
concept
is really cool is just there's some
fine-tuning with the execution that
probably just needs to be handled a
little bit because I mean you post
regularly senior Instagram page a lot of
hot ass chicks on there by the way so
good job on that photography page we've
reached through a couple of your other
videos if this is one video called the
[ __ ] which I thought was pretty
entertaining yeah and you even have like
the constipated song on there so you
definitely know how to film and you
definitely have a lot of cool ideas and
I imagine this is something you
venturing off with something a little
deeper and for projects like this yeah
the way you compose it has to just be a
little bit more fine-tuned one step at a
time I would just start with getting
some type of mic or some type of boom or
whatever someone to help you out with
that because that'll make a world of
difference in whatever you execute
actually you can do the reverse side
where you improve everything else and
then you don't improve the sound and it
won't feel improved yeah I would start
right there yeah start on the sound and
start on just maybe making some
different transitions between your shots
like it's a good visual note to start on
maybe do a little bit more storyboarding
like I think the majority of keeping in
the two-shot is cool and I like having
those shots there but sometimes the jump
cuts were distracting as opposed to
enhancing so yeah like cutting between
each character occasionally I think
would just naturally improve it I don't
know if we're like upsetting you we
wanted to give you know we're getting
constructive criticism are our opinion
yeah I mean I really appreciate you
that's like it's to engage with everyone
having creative 'ti to ask past people
to check out your work is a big feat I
think like I'd be scared unless they're
around me then I'll ask them to check it
out but I've never asked people you know
we were in the reaction world people to
do that for us
criticized a surface which is happened
yeah keep on keeping on chugging and
refining and stuff yeah dude I mean
you're multi-talented guy I mean you
told me you're an author you're
photographer and of course you're a
filmmaker so you've been doing so much
stuff
obviously you're a jack-of-all-trades so
just keep at it man I'm sure you know
how to
improve whatever you think needs to be
improved and I think the last thing that
you'd want is for people just to tell
you yes great on every single thing in
the world nor are we here to
intentionally criticize anything because
like we said this concept is really cool
just some fine-tuning on the execution
in your solid plan alright guys well
Jean getter cheater GG know it's it it's
in the message no I didn't read in read
it okay
I don't read the messages alright I just
replied to the last word he said patreon
my message I don't know a little strung
out it's just because you chose a weird
last day alright guys well you could
check out Jean jetters don't Jim page
link in the description box he's got
some awesome videos on there we saw a
couple of other ones and chair house
Instagram page especially yes can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about hey check us on
patreon TV show reactions q and A's
would love to have you become a patron
Jack the deck